[Music]
is there any way we can increase our
chances for a long and healthy life Dr
Joel wallik explains why most chronic
and degenerative diseases are
preventable through proper nutrition
you'll learn why people in certain
cultures throughout our world typically
live well over 120 years with almost no
incidence of cancer heart disease Di
diabetes or other common illnesses that
shorten human life you'll also learn the
vital role that minerals play in
maintaining our health and why our
modern diets are sorely lacking in these
life- sustaining nutrients listen now to
a live presentation by a man who is
making a Major Impact in the field of
alternative medicine Dr Joel
[Music]
wallik well I'm certainly glad you're
here how many of you grew up on a farm
or still work a farm or have anything to
do with livestock I'll tell you what
you're my kind of people because I grew
up on a farm in West St Louis County and
we started out with beef Cales and uh if
if you raise livestock the only way it
can make money is if you raise a lot of
your own feed for those of you don't
have that experience and so we raised
our own corn and we raised our own
soybeans and our own hay and we had a
truck come out from the mill and this
truck would come out from the mill
and it would grind up the corn and the
soybeans and the hay and then we would
add sacks of vitamins minerals trace
minerals and we' make pellets out of it
and this is what we would feed the Cales
in 6 months time we'd ship them to
Market to be slaughtered we'd save back
some of the best ones for oursel we'd
knock them in the head and eat them put
it bluntly and um it always fascinated
me as a teenager that we did that for
those calves and in six months ship them
off to be slaughtered or we'd eat them
and we wanted to live to be hundred
years of age without any aches and pains
and guess what we didn't take any
vitamins or minerals and that bothered
me so I asked my dad I'd say hey Pops
how come you do that for those Cavs you
don't do that for us and he'd give me
this good old Missouri farm wisdom he'd
say things like shut up boy you're
getting this farm fresh food and we hope
you appreciate it and of course I was
very quiet then because I didn't want to
miss out on any meals well then when I
went to school I went to the University
of Missouri school of Agriculture and I
got my degree in agriculture I got my
major in animal husbandry and nutrition
my minor was in field crops and soils
then I got into veterinary school as a
freshman Veterinary student I learned
the answer to my question and the answer
is this we know how to prevent and cure
diseases in animals with nutrition and
the reason why we do that is because we
don't have major medical we don't have
hospitalization Blue Cross Blue Shield
we don't have Medicare if you're going
to make money as a farmer you better
know how to do stuff yourself and you
better do it efficiently with with feed
and nutrition if you can to make a long
story short after I got out of
veterinary school I went to Africa for
two years and I was able to fulfill a
Boyhood dream I was able to be a Frank
Buck for two years and work with Marlon
Perkins many of you will remember him
from the Mutual of Omaha's Wild Kingdom
and he's a great gentleman and after two
years of working with elephants and
rhino people used to ask me are you a
small animal vet or a large animal vet
well I was tell them I'm a extra large
animal vet because I work with elephants
and rhinos well after two years he sent
me a telegram and said would you come
back to the St Louis Zoo and work with
us we need a Wildlife veterinarian at
the zoo for a special project we're
given a $7.5 million Grant from the
National Institutes of Health and what
we need is a veterinarian who will do
autopsies of animals that die of natural
causes in the zoo oh I was just
Overjoyed to do that and so I came back
and and of course I not only did
autopsies for animals that died in the
St Louis Zoo but the Brookfield Zoo in
Chicago the Bron zoo in New York the
National Zoo Zoo the LA Zoo and so forth
and my job again was to do autopsies of
animals that died of natural causes in
the zoo and look for a species of
animals that was Ultra sensitive to
pollution this is because during the
early 60s we had just learned about
pollution and ecological problems and
disasters and nobody quite knew what to
do and so I was supposed to find a
species of animals that was extra
sensitive and use them much like we did
the canaries in the mine you know the
old Welsh coal miners used to put a
canary in a little Wick cage and take it
down in the mine and if methane gas or
carbon monoxide would leak into the mine
the canary would drop off the perch and
die first and the men knew to get out
before the mine blew up or they
suffocated again to make a long story
short uh over a period of some 12 years
I did
17,500 autopsies and over 454 species of
animals and 3,000 human beings who lived
in close proximity to zoos and the thing
that I found out was this every animal
and human being who dies of natural
causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency and that fascinated me it
went back took me back to those calves I
said Gee that's fascinating we could
document this at autopsy both chemically
and biochemically and things you saw
with the eye at the autopsy table well
that fascinated me and I wrote
scientific articles I wrote uh eight
multi-author textbooks and one textbook
of my own caus 140 bucks for medical
students and I'm sure the only thing
they do is use them for door stops and
it couldn't get anybody excited I was on
2020 uh I was on 1700
newspapers I was in magazines I was in
every Network TV that you can think of
and guess what couldn't get anybody
excited back in the 60s about nutrition
so what I did was went back to school
and became a physician to use everything
I had learned in veterinary school about
nutrition and my human patients and to
no surprise to me it worked spent 12
years up in Portland argon in general
practice and um it was very fascinating
what I'm going to share with with you
tonight is what I learned over those 10
12 years using nutrition with my human
patients and if you take home only 10%
it will save you an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery it will save you a
Gob of money and those of you in
Missouri know what that means a Gob
means a lot okay it'll add many helpful
years to your life well you can't do
this you can't get these helpful years
and you can't have longevity you can't
live to your genetic potential just
falling off a stump uh you have to do
some things and the first thing I have
to do is convince you that it is worth
doing these things I'm going to start
out by convincing you that the genetic
potential for human beings is 120 years
our genetic potential for longevity in
May 11th the oldest living American at
this time and documented through the
Guinness World Book of Records was
Margaret ski she was from Radford
Virginia she died at age
115 and she died of a nutritional
deficiency tell that from her her
obituary she died of the complications
of a fall what did she die from
osteoporosis very good she died of a
Calcium deficiency she had no heart
disease no cancer no diabetes no other
infirmities but she died three weeks
after a fall because she didn't have
enough calcium her daughter said that
she had a craving for sweets until she
died and that's a a disease called Pica
we'll talk about that in a little bit
but usually when you have a craving for
chocolate if you're a chocaholic or a
sugarholic
uh that means that you have a deficiency
then in a third world country in Niger
in Africa a chief by the name of Bower
at age 126 was eulogized by one of his
wives and she was bragging about him at
his death at age 126 he was still in
possession of all his own teeth okay so
you assume that other faculties are
working
too then here's a gentleman uh from
Syria at age 133 he died in July of 1993
he fathered nine children after the age
of 80 and this meant if you add up nine
months for each child and a year for
breastfeeding for each one and a year
between each one of the children he was
still fathering children after age of a
100 so there's still hope for you
fellas then those of you who like
science um in November of
1993 those six biospherians came out of
that dome in Arizona they were in there
for 2 years three couples and they were
supposed to eat the perfect food and
recycle the atmosphere and grow their
own food and whatnot and have no
pollution in their water or air or food
and when they came out they were
examined by medical gerontologist from
UCLA University of California Los
Angeles they put all this information
their physical and their blood work and
so forth into the medical computers at
UCLA and the medical computers projected
that they could live to be 165 years old
if they continued to do what they were
doing so all of that just says to you
that there's a there's a possibility you
can live to be 120 and when I grew up on
the farm we could grow 200 bushels of
corn per acre and with all the labor and
all the fertilizer and everything else
you did you could make a profit if you
grew 200 bushels per acre but if you
only got a 100 bushels per acre and put
out that same effort and the same
fertilizer cost you'd lose
money and so I want you to think about
it the average lifespan for an American
today is
75.5 average lifespan for an MD or a
doctor is
58 you want to gain 20 years
statistically just don't go to medical
school you want to live to be 120
there's only two basic things real
simple two things to remember number one
you have to avoid the pitfalls you have
to not step on the landmines I call it
and those of you in the military you
know what that means you do something
stupid like step on one of those things
you kill yourself wastefully or
unnecessarily and of course if you play
Russian Roulette or smoke excessively or
drink excessively or wear a black
sweatsuit and run down the middle of the
highway at 2:00 in the morning you're
going to get struck by by a car uh all
of those things are fool hearty but it's
amazing how many tens of thousands of
people die in America from doing those
stupid things every year the last thing
I will share with you on that subject of
avoiding the landmines i' suggest very
strongly to you that you avoid going to
doctors and I'm going to back up that
statement which is a pretty strong
statement from Ralph nater's group in
January of
1993 just about a year and a half ago uh
January 13th he put out a news release
based on a three-year study on the
causes of death in American hospitals
and it was 1500 page report this
threeyear study and I'm not going to
waste your time or Mine by going over
the whole thing word for word but the
bottom line says a lot quote 300,000
Americans are killed each year in
hospitals alone as a result of medical
negligence unquote I'm going to read
that figure again because it's a huge
figure quote 300,000 Americans are
killed each year in hospitals alone as a
result of medical negligence unquote now
he didn't say Slipped Away quietly out
of neglect in a Conner somewhere while
they're waiting for an x-ray he used the
word killed when you use the word killed
that means there was a procedure the
doctor was doing went wrong somehow that
means that they gave them a wrong
prescription they put a decimal point in
the wrong spot and gave them an
incorrect dosage these people were
killed 300,000 to appreciate how big a
figure that is you have to compare that
with our military losses in Vietnam over
10 years where we lost 56,000 people
over 10 years or an average of only
5,600 a year on a field of battle where
people had guns and artillery and
explosives trying to kill each other and
millions of people poured out into the
streets and protested that war we had
political Anarchy in the last three
years of the war students took over
universities and colleges with guns and
explosives National Guardsman shot
students at Kent State in Ohio we chased
a president out of the presidency for
5,600 military personnel a year and
here's one profession that takes your
taxx money in the form of Medicare and
Medicaid and kills 300,000 of us a year
according to Ralph nater and I believe
him he has no ax to grind and you can go
out in the street any day of the week in
any City and there isn't even a crazy
Street Preacher out there with a sign
that says protect us from
doctors I want you to think about that
folks that's number one you have to
avoid stepping on the landmine so
there's a certain value in treating
yourself when you can or preventing
disease so you don't have to get treated
now the second thing you have to do
number two is you have to do the
positive things you have to do the
positive things and I'm going to start
out here by just putting a figure up on
the board it's the number 90 and you
need 90 nutrients in your diet every day
you need 60 minerals you need 16
vitamins you need 12 essential amino
acids or protein building blocks and you
need three essential fatty acids you
need 90 nutrients in your daily diet
otherwise you're going to get a
deficiency disease if you don't have
them in complete numbers and optimal
amounts I can tell you that I was one of
those nerds back when I was in college I
had a clipboard we didn't have computers
back then so I had a clipboard and I I
was one of those funny guys with glasses
and would walk up and down in the
Student Union there in Columbia and say
uh do you take vitamins and minerals I
was still fascinated by that and and of
course people kind of look at you crazy
and say well yeah I take vitamin E and
I'd wait for him to come up with the
other 89 and they didn't they just oh I
take vitamin E well today if you ask
people do you take food supplements they
say oh yeah I take
Tums because that's what you know they
hear all the time well again you need 90
nutrients if you're going to make it but
the newspapers know and the magazines
and TV and radio knows that we're
interested in Health and Longevity and
and supplements so they all talk to us
not because the medical profession has
asked them to do that in their stad the
medical profession doesn't say hey we're
so busy saving people with surgery and
chemotherapy and radiation and
pharmaceuticals would you please educate
the people on nutrition they do it
because it's sells newspapers well my
favorite article of all time appeared in
Time Magazine April 6th 1992 and if you
haven't read it I'd urge you to get it
out of a school library or public
library and photocopy it stick one copy
on the door in the bathroom and one on
the refrigerator it's a cover article it
says the real power of vitamins new
research shows they may help fight
cancer heart disease and the ravages of
Aging again there's six positive pages
in here there's only one negative
sentence and was issued by a medical
doctor who is asked by the of the
article what do you think what do you
think about vitamins and minerals for
people as food supplements and here's
what the doctor said quote popping
vitamins doesn't do you any good sniffs
Dr Victor Herbert a professor of
medicine at New York City's Mount Sinai
Medical School we get all the vitamins
we need in our diets and taking
supplements just gives you expensive
urine unquote well to give you a
Missouri translation of that that means
you're just peeing away your dollars if
you take vitamins and minerals you might
as well W up your dollars and throw them
in the toilet and flush them away
because you're not getting any redeeming
value from it those quacks are just
taking your money for those vitamins and
minerals that's what he was trying to
say got published so it must be true
right after having done those
17,500 autopsies and 454 species of
animals from around the world and 3,000
humans and liking to be healthy myself
and having children and grandchildren
and not two distant future
great-grandchildren I'd rather pee out
50 cents or a dollar a day worth of
excess vitamins and minerals it's it's
pretty cheap insurance if you don't
invest in yourself to the tune of a buck
a day for vitamins and minerals guess
what you're going to invest in the
lifestyle of a MD somewhere because when
you pay the medical doctor your fee for
going to see him not one penny of that
goes to study how to diagnose or treat
or prevent a catastrophic disease in a
little child like who was in here
earlier or how to prevent or diagnose or
treat better breast cancer or prostate
cancer in adults guess what that money
goes for pays the doctor's mortgage
makes his Mercedes payment it pays a
tuition for his kids to go to medical
school at havid you know where havid is
up in Baston pays a tuition for his kids
to go to law school at Yale between 1776
and the second world war the US
government spent $80 million on
Healthcare and healthc Care research and
studies right now we're at
1.2 trillion dollar a year for healthc
care and it's free we all know it's free
free right it's not free but we're
supposed to believe it's free and
everybody wants more of it and more free
stuff well I'll tell you what if we used
a human type medical system for the
agricultural industry and the livestock
your hamburger cost $275 a pound on the
other hand if you use the agricultural
health system that we use in animals for
humans your monthly insurance premiums
for a family of five would be $10 a
month you take your choice well I
believe since we've made them wealthy
through Insurance programs and
government subsidies I believe they owe
us something and I believe they owe us
at least as much as the industries do
according to for instance recall notices
this was started of course I don't know
25 years ago when Ralph nater learned
that the Ford Motor Company had made a
pinto car with a rear-end gas tank that
would blow up when you got hit from
behind at 20 M hour fry everybody in the
car and when people complained to Ford
Motor Company they said well you're just
dumb for getting in a car accident we're
not going to pay you for that
Ralph nater says no it's a faulty design
so he went to a federal court and the
judge agreed with him and through a
court order forced for Motor Company to
send everybody a uh recall notice with a
registered letter bring that car in and
they'll fix it for nothing but they kill
300,000 a year and nobody protests as
long as we get ours free and that scares
me that attitude at any rate I've got a
bunch of these recall notices you should
have gotten over the last couple years
we'll go through them quickly number one
is ulcers how many of you ever heard
that ERS is caused by
stress okay everybody's heard that if
you don't raise your hand you got
Alzheimer's or your fibon
right well we knew 50 years ago in in
the veterinary industry that ulcers at
least in pigs was caused by a bacteria
called helicobactor pylor and of course
we couldn't get one of these high pric
stomach surgeons from Mayo Clinic in
fact we always used to yell hold the
Mayo when they'd say stuff like that
otherwise your pork jobs would be $275 a
pound to pay for that kind of surgery
and we learned that with a trace mineral
called bisma and the tetracycline
antibiotic that we could prevent and and
cure those stomach ulcers and pigs
without surgery and so that's what we
did cost five bucks to cure a pig of
stomach ulcers with bismuth the trace
mineral and tetracycline well the
National Institutes of Health now not
the national Inquirer but the National
Institutes of Health came out in
February 1994 and said ulcers are caused
by a bacteria called helicobactor pylori
not stress and they can be cured they
actually use the Cure word in this news
release medical researchers never do
that they always say it shows promising
results or may be beneficial they use
the Cure word National Institutes of
Health they say can be cured with a
combination of the trace mineral bismuth
and
tetracycline well for those of you who
don't know what bismo comes in you can
get it from any grocery store or
drugstore it's pink about 295 for an 8
oun bottle and it's called Pepto Bismol
so a teaspoon a day full of Pepto Bismol
and some Aris CF scour pellets you can
take care of ulcers
now you have your choice whether you're
going to treat your own for five bucks
or go get Whitted on that's your choice
then what's the number two cause of
death in Americans terrible disease
called cancer right now when doctors get
information on cancer you'd think they'd
photocopy that and when they send you
that bill they should send you some
photocopies of this stuff well in
September of 1993 the um National Cancer
Institute not the national Inquirer but
the National Cancer Institute and the um
havid Medical School up in Baston did a
study on cancer patients and they came
out and they said an anti-cancer diet
was found well at any rate they picked
China to do this study because in one
Province henan Province in China they
have the highest rate of cancer in the
whole world they took 29,000 people for
5 years in this study and what they did
was give them different vitamins and
minerals at Double the recommended daily
allowance for Americans now that's a
trivial amount for instance they use
vitamin C for one group and of course
the um RDA recommended daily allowance
for vitamin C is 60 milligram double
that it's can be 120 milligram you can't
go into a health food store and find a
vitamin C tablet or capsule for less
than 500 milligrams for an adult and of
course lonis Pauling the gentleman with
two Nobel prizes says if you want to
prevent and treat cancer with vitamin C
you got to use 10,000 milligrams a day
well all the doctors who used to argue
with him back 35 years ago are all dead
and today lonus Pauling still 94 and he
works 14 hours a day seven days a week
on his Ranch in the Big Sir in
California and teaches at the University
of California San Francisco so you have
to make up your choice whether you're
going to listen to the Dead Doctors or
lonus Pauling your choice okay vitamin C
double the RDA nothing happened vitamin
A Double the RDA nothing happened zinc
riboflavin the trace mineral mbum nin
nothing happened in one group they got a
major benefit in this group they got
three nutrients at one time they got
vitamin E they got beta carotene and the
trace mineral selenium that those three
were at Double the RDA and if you get a
half a percent benefit in any
nutritional or pharmaceutical experiment
you've made a major Improvement in
Humanity's life and so these articles
get published so I want you to remember
that statistic a half a percent is major
benefit well in this group that received
the vitamin E beta carotene and selenium
for 5 years deaths from all causes were
reduced by 9% almost 10 out of every
hundred or one out of every 10 who were
going to die in that 5 Years From Any
cause
survived then cancers all cancers 133%
survived who would have died without
those three
nutrients so 13 out of 100 lived who
would have died and then the type of
cancer that was most prevalent in henan
Province stomach and esophageal cancer
21% lived who would have died 21 out of
100 lived now to me those are
significant numbers and your physician
for the number two cause of death in
America should have sent every one of
you a photocopy that at least giving you
information even if he didn't want to
give you the advice give you the
information let you make up your own
mind well here's one I think is funny on
one hand and on the other side it tells
you the attitude of Physicians this has
to do with arthritis it was in September
24th 1993 that it was released again it
was from the havid medical school in the
Baston VA Hospital how many of you in
here have ever been to a VA Hospital
anybody in this room okay good well you
know the people who've been to a VA
Hospital you have two opportunities to
give your life for your country once on
the field of battle and the other is in
the VA Hospital right
well at any rate the title of the
release was chicken protein halts the
swelling and pain of arthritis in a
patient trial and what they did they
took people who failed to respond in any
way to medical treatment for arthritis
these people got gold shots mesot
trexate they got uh aspirin prednizone
cortisone everything else you can think
of physical therapy and the only thing
left for them was joint replacement
surgery okay now before Harvard Medical
School the VA hospital was going to give
it to them they said look we're looking
for some people who are will to suffer
for 90 more days just 3 months because
we want to try something a short-term
experiment and they got 29 volunteers
and what they did for those 29
volunteers who failed to respond in any
way to medical treatment for arthritis
was they gave them a heaping teaspoonful
of ground up dried chicken cartilage in
their orange juice every morning just a
heaping teaspoon of ground up chicken
cartilage and in 10 days according to
Harvard Medical School all the pain and
inflammation was gone these are people
who didn't respond in any way to medical
treatment in 30 days they could open up
a new pickle jar that never been opened
and 90 days 3 months they had maximum
return of function here's the funny part
the funny part comes by a statement of
the guy who was the director of that
study from Harvard Medical School and
here's what he said quote listen to the
words are very important quote after
three months it was clear that the drug
was beneficial unquote because it worked
chicken cartilage had become a
drug you can see he's think about patent
numbers and his eyes are rolling around
with 300 bucks a capsule 20 patients and
you can just see him calculating
right that means if you go to Kentucky
Fried Chicken and you buy a bucket of
chicken throw away the skin and the meat
and eat the ends off the bones you're
practicing medicine without a
license and if you go to a Kentucky
Fried Chicken in the middle of the night
in the dark of the night and you go to
their dumpster and you root through
there and you collect two five gallon
feed buckets full of chicken bones and
you take them home with a hammer and you
pound off the ends of those bones and
dry your own cartilage in the microwave
you know you're manufacturing a
pharmaceutical and the FDA is going to
put you in jail next time I come by here
in 3 months you're going to run up on
this stage and hug me and kiss me if you
got arthritis how many you have ever
heard of Alzheimer's disease everybody's
heard about it today 50 years ago when I
was a little kid there's no such thing
as Alzheimer's disease it's a new
disease one of those things that just
sort of happened now it's a major
disease one out of every two people who
reach age 70 get Alzheimer's disease is
pretty scary we learned 50 years ago in
the animal industry how to prevent and
cure in the early stages Alzheimer's
disease and livestock you imagine how
much a farmer would lose if the pigs
were all laying there scratching their
head saying why am I
here where is the feed box because if
they're not gaining a couple of pounds a
day you're losing money right so we
learned in the agricultural industry how
to prevent in the early stages cure
Alzheimer's disease and we do it with
high doses of vitamin E and low intakes
of vegetable oil you you say wall like
that's crazy high doses of vitamin E
well you should have got a recall notice
from your doctor in July of 1992 because
the University of California I mean
we're talking about a sophisticated
research medical school here University
of California San Diego came out and
said vitamin E eases memory loss in
Alzheimer's victims now they're only 50
years behind on that from veterinary
medicine so it might be safer going to a
veterinarian then how many of you in
this room ever had a kidney stone
anybody in here ever get that kidney
stone okay I see a few in here what's
the first thing a doctor told you to
give up nutritionally when you got your
kidney stone give up calcium no Dairy no
Dairy none of those vitamin mineral
things with calcium in them because they
have the stupid naive ignorant belief
that's pretty intense they have the
stupid ignorant naive belief that the
calcium in your kidney stone comes from
the calcium you eat when in fact it
comes from your own bones when you have
a raging Calcium deficiency a raging
osteoporosis then you get kidney stones
we learned years ago in writing in the
agricultural industry if you wanted to
prevent kidney stones and livestock you
better give them more calcium you better
give them more magnesium and more Boron
the reason is of course bulls and rams
male cattle and sheep have special
Anatomy when they get a kidney stone
they die they call water belly they die
when you and I get a kidney stone we
just wish we were dead but no farmer is
dumb enough to pay for the feed for an
animal and have it die before you can
either eat it or send it to Market so we
learned how to prevent those things well
you should have got a recall notice from
your doctor especially you people who've
had kidney stones your urologist should
have sent a notice to you this was uh
March of 1993 it says uh calcium limits
kidney stone risk and this is from the
havid medical school up in Baston by the
way in a study that turns conventional
medical wisdom on its head researchers
have found that people whose diets are
rich in calcium run a reduced risk of
developing kidney stones in a study of
more than 45,000 people that who were
ranked into five categories the group
that had the most calcium had no kidney
stones now about 5 years ago when I
started out on this Crusade and started
lecturing to people all across America
and I'm in one time zone and the next
and uh all over I knew I was going to
get crazy out there uh doing this last
year I was on the road 300 days out of
the Year 300 out of 365 days and so I
decided I needed to have a hobby that I
could take with me every time I get a
little wacko I could go in my room and
do this Hobby and I'd be okay you know
be kind of like having a little piece of
home with me wherever I went and I
wanted to have a hobby that would uh uh
help other people I didn't want to
collect baseball cards cuz I like
football and I didn't want to do just
crossword puzzles cuz good mental
exercise but wouldn't help anybody else
and um I couldn't take my compost pile I
like the garden and the hotels don't
like that you know so I decided I was
going to collect obituaries of doctors
and
lawyers now as crazy as that sounds
remember I told you the doctors live to
an average age of 58 and we live to 75.5
and here's a group of people
professionals who pontificate you and
tell you well this is what you need to
do you need to give up salt and uh no
caffeine and you need to not eat butter
and eat margarine and do all these crazy
things and they die at age 58 on the
average and anyway got a few of them
here some of my favorites this doctor
steuart cartright aged 38 he dropped
dead in his home he was a family
practitioner of a ruptured aneurysm
that's a ballooning of an artery that's
a weakened artery because of the
fragmenting or the brittle condition of
the elastic fibers and arteries just
like when you hit a Chuck hole with your
car tire and you break the cords in
there and you get a balloon he dropped
dead like he was poleaxed okay right in
his home from a ruptured aneurysm and we
learned in 19 oh I think it was uh
57 aneurysms are caused by a copper
deficiency we had a pilot project
turkeys and we made complete food
pellets where you put all the 90
nutrients in there and in the first 13
weeks fully half of those turkeys died
farmers were out there every morning
picking them up by the bushel basket
they took them to the state diagnostic
labs and they're autopsy and they found
out that they all had died from a
ruptured a Artic aneurysm so they
doubled the amount of copper in there
and the next year they didn't lose a
single turkey from a ruptured a Artic
aneurysm and they ran that experiment in
mice and rats and rabbits and dogs and
cats and uh calves and sheep and pigs
and whatnot and guess what they found
out that there's a whole series of
diseases that are caused by a copper
deficiency gray hair is the first sign
when you started getting here regardless
of your age you got a copper deficiency
you get skin wrinkles because the
elastic fibers in your skin are going
those little crows feet around your eyes
and facial and body skin wrinkles you
look like you're a little prune drying
up okay then of course there's the um
varicose
veins that's caused by an elastic fiber
breakdown then of course parts of your
body begin to Sag under your arms your
breast your bellies your legs all this
stuff starts sagging and you can go to a
cosmetic surgeon a plastic surgeon if
you want but it's a lot cheaper and a
lot more effective and a lot safer if
you just take some copper Dr cartrite
may have had a medical degree but he
didn't have expensive urine so he die to
something that even a turkey Wouldn't
Die from then here's one this fellow he
was a doctor's doctor Dr Martin Carter
he almost made it he died at age
57 he got his medical degree from havit
medical school and his PhD in medicine
from Yale he was autopsied by the best
cuz he was a doctor's doctor he said
quote the cause of death was a rupture
AR aneurism said Dr Jules HS the
Rockefeller University Hospital unquote
what did he die from copper deficiency
see he didn't have expensive urine
either then here's an attorney she was
so famous she was from Detroit age 44
Ellen Joyce alter uh she was in the New
York Times obituary she made the big
time and uh of course she probably had
steel buns because she belonged to one
of those private health clubs all these
gals want steel buns you know doing
their little
exercises but she didn't have expensive
urine because she died of a ruptured
cerebral
aneurysm when they don't do an autopsy
the symptoms could be called a stroke or
uh subdural Hemorrhage but very
frequently they're caused by a ruptured
aneurysm which is a copper deficiency
she didn't have expensive urine how many
of you here have ever heard of a guy by
the name of Stuart Burger Stuart Burger
he he wrote five best-selling books on
health and diets and nutrition he got
his medical degree from tough's medical
school which is a very fine medical
school in Boston not too far away from
uh Harvard Medical School and the books
he wrote included the Southampton diet
for weight loss he wrote Forever Young
20 years younger and 20 weeks and how to
be your own nutritionist and he died at
age 40 how'd you like to follow his
dietary practices he died at age 40 of
cardiomyopathy which is a selenium
deficiency the same cause as white
muscle disease or or stiff lamb disease
and any farmer can go to a feed store
and get selenium pellets or selenium
injections things like celotto and boy
and so forth and Dr Stuart burer a guy
who wrote five best-selling books on
nutrition died of a nutritional
deficiency he didn't have expensive
urine you can prevent totally prevent
cardiomyopathy for 10 cents a day and if
we don't do it we're malignant dumb I
like to call it you're malignant dumb if
you don't take in 10 cents a day worth
of selenium it's a waste of your life
that's one of those landmines you can
avoid the medical treatment of choice
for cardiomyopathy is a heart transplant
cost
$750,000 I want you to think about that
they get the heart free from a donor
they get the blood free for the surgery
from the relatives they use $2.50 worth
of suture material and they charge a
$750,000 for that procedure now 6 months
ago in La when they had the earthquake
they were putting people in jail for 60
and 90 days for price gouging for
selling these terrified people a gallon
of water for
$4 they put them in jail for price
gouging for selling him a gallon of
water for four bucks now to me that's
entrepreneurialism you know that's being
in business for yourself if you had a a
way to distill water and make water and
you had a car and you could get in there
and sell those people a gallon of water
for four bucks hey more power to you
because if you go to a 711 and buy a
quart of Evan water it's
$129 so four of those quarts is a five
bucks kind of interesting isn't it they
said it was price gouging because those
people were terrified well talk about a
person who needs a new heart they're
terrified
$750,000 we should put those doctors in
jail but we bow to them because oh
that's high-tech medicine out of $27
million people in America you save about
50 a year is that cost effective I don't
think so Dr Stuart burer didn't have
expensive urine here's the last one and
many of you may know this woman uh her
name was Dr Gail Clark she was age 47
she was the chief cardiologist of the
West St Louis County group of hospitals
uh she was a chief cardiologist for the
um St Mary's Health Center in Richmond
High in St Louis County she was aged 47
guess what she died from heart attack a
cardiopathy heart attack you can just
see her walking down the hall she got
the stethoscope around her neck you know
this is their little status symbol got
my stethoscope around my neck back when
I was in school they folded it up very
bravely and put it in their pocket boom
she falls down she has a heart attack
right in the hall and of course the
nurses scoop her up and put her on a
gurnie and they call the technicians and
another Docker code three code three
code blue whatever it is and they whiper
into the room and you can hear them
let's say cardiac patient you're laying
there you're all hooked up to the
monitors and the IVs and and you hear
them say Okay tear clothes off okay
stand back didn't work turn it up stand
back and then you hear that terrible
sound when you know that the treatment
didn't
work the flat line when you know the
heart is gone and everybody walks out of
the room dejected and you say nurse
nurse what happened next door and she
says well your cardiologist you know the
chief cardiologist of this Hospital age
47 Dr Gail Clark just died of a
cardiomyopathy heart attack we can see
all the patients they're holding their
gowns and they're running out of that
hospital leaving their watches and their
shoes and their checkbooks and
everything and their plastic credit
cards because they don't want to get
what Dr Gail Clark got to me the Readers
Digest is a magazine that never says
anything negative or bad about anybody
or any group it's the sweetest little
magazine that ever was the September
1993 issue features an article it says
can you trust your doctor it lists 12
ways that doctors scam your money and
I'll let you read 11 of them yourself
I'll give you the worst one in addition
to their income from Office fees and
surgical fees and lab fees and
hospitalization doctors get a kickback
from the labs and the the X-ray labs and
Clinics and hospitals they get a
kickback of
$421 every time they send you in for a
CAT scan or an
MRI and doctors tell you oh we do that
because we're practicing defensive
medicine because if I miss something you
know one in 10 billion you're going to
sue me so I do this just to protect
myself well if it was just to protect
themselves and you knew them and they
knew you 90% of the people say I'll just
skip it DOC if you don't really think
it's necessary let's save the money but
they got something more than defensive
medicine to worry about they get 421
bucks in a kickback for every time they
send you in for an MRI or a CAT scan
well when I practiced for 12 years up in
Portland somebody come to me with a
terrible headache never had one I'd just
walk up to them and tap them on the
sinuses and if they collapsed to their
knees I know they had a sinus headache
oh die why'd you do that well I just
wanted that's a cheap lab test you
know then if they had thank you if they
had blood dripping out of their nose it
take a $35 x-ray to see if they had a
cancer in there 35 bucks in a free lab
test as opposed to 421 bucks if I wanted
to make that 421 bucks I'd have been a
good Thief what I'd have done I'd have
build a chute right into that cat scan
machine cuz I knew how to build shoots
living on a farm and I'd have gone out
in the street and I'd have got every
homeless person I'd line them up in them
shoots and I'd put soup in a MIG Mac at
the end of that tube you know and I'd
say I'm going to give buy you $150
dinner I'm a good guy I'm going to buy
you a $150 dinner you just got to go
through the shoot go through that tube
and you get your sandwich and your soup
man they'd be flowing through there
maybe a hundred a day and I could start
adding some things up it'd be a lot of
fun any rate the average doctor gets
$228,600 you do that politicians
lawyers
businessmen stock Brokers they get put
in jail but doctors it's okay because
insurance pays for it we don't mind if
they steal it's blind it's free remember
I told you I was going to tell you about
Pica Pica is a funny disease Pica I'm
not talking about the type style that
you see in typewriters and computers but
p is a disease that farmers know about
uh in horses it's called cribbing when
they chew on the feed bunk the wooden
feed bunk you know you better give them
some minerals otherwise they're going to
eat that feed bunk and cattle dairy
cattle especially where they're losing
lots of minerals through their milk all
the time intensive milking you'll see
them picking up big rocks in the creek
and chewing on them or they'll chew on
Bob wire or maybe you'll see them
walking down through a path with a deer
bone in their mouth or something or a
shingle that's called Pica and a good
farmer husband drean knows you better
give them some minerals otherwise are
going to eat the barn or something in
human beings we see this at funny times
pregnant women are notorious for Pica uh
in the middle of the night they'll elbow
their husband and say Hey you better get
up I want some uh pickles and ice cream
they're craving minerals because that
fetus is pulling minerals out of their
body they need some more minerals and so
it's it's recognized as a craving for
things like sweets and salt we see this
in pregnant women I used to have people
come to my practice and they say doct do
I need to go see a shrink I said why is
that well I wake up in the middle of the
night and I I go outside with a spoon
and I eat dirt and no that's okay just
make sure it's clean dirt
then they say my my kid sits there with
a kitty litter box between his legs and
he has a spoon and he's eating that
stuff out of the kitty litter box and
then in housing projects little kids
will eat lead paint off the walls and
they get lead poison get learning
disabilities and Bone problems and
anemia and we're good so we spend $5
million to scrape the lead paint off of
there and repaint it with latex paint
and all you have to do is give those
kids 10 cents a day worth of minerals it
be better for them and save us 5 million
bucks it's your tax money and if we
allow him to throw them away those
dollars is kind of interesting if you
have a selenium deficiency and you don't
want to wait until you get cardiopathy
and drop dead from a heart attack to
recognize it if you look on your hands
and look in the mirror in your face if
you have liver spots or age spots and I
see quite a few from
here you have an early selenium
deficiency that's called free radical
damage and fortunately for you if you
recognize that and you start taking in
some selenium in four to 6 months those
will go away you'll reverse that in four
to six months and when they go away on
the outside they're going away on the
inside your brain and your heart and
your liver and your kidneys and if you
have low blood sugar how many in this
room have low blood sugar anybody in
here have low blood sugar okay about 10%
how many you ever seen a hyperactive kid
who gets on sugar okay about everybody
in the room people who have sugar
problems are like alcoholics there's
good ones and bad ones you know the good
alcoholics are one when they get two
drinks they just go off in a corner and
go to sleep right same way with somebody
with low blood sugar they eat a big meal
or they eat a piece of pie 3 hours later
they clunk out and go to sleep then
there's bad alcoholics they're the one
that gets two drinks in them and they
get violent and raged and they want to
fight everybody punch holes in the wall
you know big Brave fellows and they kick
their wife and kick the dog and take the
chainsaw and cut their neighbor tree
down and all these wild things and drive
Reckless down the roads and kill people
those are the bad drunks well people who
have blood sugar problems are bad blood
sugar people too they get a little crazy
okay I don't know how many of you
remember the twinkie
defense right remember somebody murdered
two people and he claimed he ate a
Twinkie three hours before he murdered
him so they let him off because he got
temporarily insane every time he ate
sugar now don't any of you try that well
chromium and vadium deficiency will
result in the sugar problems low blood
sugar and if you let it go on for any
length of time you develop diabetus
chromium and vadium then a tin
deficiency the early symptoms of a tin
deficiency are male pattern baldness I
see a lot of tin deficiency in this room
yes and if you let it go on for any
length of time you get deafness then
there's a boron deficiency and you gal
should know about boron because it helps
you keep the calcium you take in in your
bones so you don't get
osteoporosis Boron also it helps you
make estrogen it helps you fellas make
testosterone if you don't take in enough
Boron you ladies are going to suffer
miserably going through menopause okay
you're going to have all those terrible
symptoms you fellas don't get enough
Boron can't make testosterone you won't
know whether to lead or follow on the D
Dance
Floor you're going to be
confused she's saying he's got a boron
deficiency the first symptoms of a zinc
deficiency is you lose your sense of
smell and your taste you say oh you know
food just doesn't taste good anymore and
you don't have a cold or anything like
that and you say your wife says well
aren't you excited about dinner I spent
the whole day in the kitchen cooking
dinner he said well I didn't smell
anything when I walked in you know he's
got a zinc deficiency
well in laboratory animals there's some
seven rare Earths these rare Earths are
trace minerals you need in lesser
amounts than you need trace minerals and
they actually double the lifespan of
laboratory animals they've not been
proven in humans yet but I'm not going
to wait 500 years for doctors to approve
it they're still arguing over vitamin C
and calcium right so I'm just going to
do it didn't kill any laboratory animals
just doubles her life and it's not a
drug these rare Earths are called
lanthum prium neodium samarium europium
ubium and thulium there must be a reason
why they're named after Old Testament
cities well remember I told you we
needed 90 nutrients we need 60 minerals
we need 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids and three essential fatty acids
and of course we're lucky in that plants
as a group can make most vitamins amino
acids and fatty acids plants can do that
because they just take carbon out of the
air and make carbon chains to make
vitamins amino acids and fatty acids but
you have to eat 15 to 25 different
plants a day in the right combinations
to make this happen theoretically it's
possible but most Americans don't do it
the average American thinks if they eat
some potato buds out of a Betty Crocker
box are eating a vegetable okay so you
got to be careful what you're
considering a vegetable then of course
people want to do right by their doctor
and they eat lowfat turkey breast and
they put a half a jar of mayonnaise on
there and they put it between two slices
of Wonder styrofoam bread remember that
stuff you can insulate your house with
and put in your shoes when you get a
hole in shoe I remember when I was a kid
it was a lot of fun because we have
Wonderbread we didn't have TVs back then
on the farm we didn't even have dryers
that went round and round so the only
thing you could do in the winter time
was sit in the kitchen and wondered a
loaf of Wonderbread and had the blue and
red and green yellow balloons on there
and if you read the label as many times
as I do you know it said things like
helps build bodies at 12 ways and about
15 years later the FDA made him change
it to help build your body eight ways
now if you go to the store and look at
Wonderbread rappers it just says
Wonderbread so it kind of gives you a
clue
so even though this is theoretically
possible it's not likely to happen that
you're going to get your vitamins amino
acids and fatty acids in proper
proportions from your diet and so if
your life is as valuable to you as mine
is to me and my children's and my
grandchildren's is to me I would make
sure that I take in all my vitamins and
amino acids and fatty acids because I
guarantee you won't make it to 120 if
you don't you're just not going to do it
now now minerals are another story we
have a tragic story when it comes to
minerals because plants cannot make
minerals in any way shape or form and if
they're not in the soil anymore they're
not in our plants our farm soils and our
rain soils are depleted of minerals and
the crops the grains the fruits and the
vegetables and the nuts that are grown
on these depleted farm and Rain soils
are minerally deficient and the people
who eat them get mineral deficiency
diseases and the only way to prevent and
cure them is with mineral supplements do
you think it's gotten any better no it
has not gotten any better it's only
gotten worse and the reason is if you
guys do what we did and people continue
to do is we put NPK on our land nitrogen
phosphorus potassium and you see it as
these three numbers in many combinations
of ratios and these represent
percentages of these three nutrients
nitrogen phosphorus pottassium and those
of you who don't have any experience on
farms the reason why we do this is
farmers get paid for tons and bushels
there's no subsidy that encourages
people to put 60 minerals back in the
soil you get paid for tons of bushels
and for 40 bucks an acre you can get the
maximum yield in tons and bushels it
only takes 5 to 10 years to deplete the
land of minerals CU every time you
harvest a crop those plants pull
minerals out of the soil many pounds per
acre every time you haul a crop out so
soon those minerals are gone and if you
only put back in three and you take out
60 it's like a checking account if you
only put three bucks in your checking
account every month and write checks for
60 what's going to happen to your checks
boing boing boing they bounce exactly
like can tell you that our health is
bouncing right now to the tune of $1.2
trillion a year it's our responsibility
each and every one of us to be
responsible for our health and
consciously take in these minerals I
have a lot of people ask me what did
these people do thousands of years ago
they didn't even have commercial
fertilizers what did they do these
societies that had long-lived people and
whatnot I want you to think about the
Egyptians the Chinese people from India
that lived around these Great Rivers the
Nile River the Ganges River the B river
in China and what used to happen was
every year or so it would flood just
like it did here in Northern Missouri
last year and every time it flooded
guess what would happen it would bring
silt or rock dust from Mountains from
500 or thousand miles away and those
people would pray to every God they had
the water God the sky God the wind God
The Rock God to flood we pray don't
flood they used to pray to flood because
they had their floods during the winter
time and would put silt and minerals
back in the soil and their grain was
very valuable King Phillip who's the
father of uh Alexander the Great married
the 12-year-old child queen of Egypt
Cleopatra she didn't look like Elizabeth
Taylor all made up in beautiful costumes
she was a little flatchested teeny
bopper not very sexy but Philip married
her because she controlled the best
wheat in the world and if he wanted his
Macedonian army to conquer the world
through his son Alexander the Great he
needed the best wheat in the world so he
could March 20 hours a day fight for 6
hours and win if they used the wheat
from the depleted soils and grease they
couldn't go 20 minutes without saying
mommy pick me up can you imagine these
big Greek soldiers Oh my legs hurt pick
me up and so they knew the best place to
get wheat was from Egypt it was those
floods that gave them those minerals and
all those cultures that came up with all
the great art and all the great
technology came from those places
because they had more intelligence
because they had more nutrition more
minerals I heard somebody say very good
you're getting the picture well what I'm
going to do here is I'm just going to
pick out a couple of minerals just a
couple of them so you get the idea it
applies to all of them let's just pick
out a common one like calcium everybody
knows about calcium Calcium deficiency
will result in something like 147
different diseases they're just
different names are named after people
like Bells paly you know everybody knows
about that one side of your face sags
it's not a true stroke it just affects
your facial muscles it's caused by
Calcium deficiency we'll talk about in a
little bit but everybody knows about
this one osteoporosis it's the number 10
killer of adults in United States it's
very expensive it costs you $335,000
each for each hip to replace it's okay
it's free insurance will pay for it cost
you $70,000 for both hips as expensive
as it is and the number 10 killer
remember Mrs ski from Radford Virginia
aged 115 years of age she died of
complications of a fall we don't have
osteoporosis and animals and it's
because of farmers we don't have
osteoporosis and animals goes like this
you have a a pasture with a hundred cows
in it and this year you didn't have any
calves you can't repay your operating
loan you're in trouble right because you
paid for the feed and the vet bill and
mow the pasture and fertilize and
maintain the fence and fed the cows and
all this that and the other you don't
have any cash you can't pay back the
operating load and make any money so you
call the vet out and you say do I get
rid of these cows what happened here and
he examines the cows he says nothing
wrong with them he says let me look at
the bull and he say aha here's your
problem that bull has osteoporosis of
both hips can't breed the cows didn't
have any calvs he says I'll I tell you
what though he says you give me $70,000
he says I'll put two new hips in that
bull and next year you'll have some
calves well the first thing that farmer
says a stand back doc
boom he blows that bull away with a deer
rifle and while the kids are grinding
the bull up with a grinder and cutting
roas and steaks off that bull the farmer
is chewing on a straw and saying now Doc
pushes ston up a little bit and he says
you know I wasn't going to pay you
$70,000 for that old bull he says I get
a new bull every year for 70 years for
that he says but every once in a while I
get get a bull that throws good calves
I'd like to keep them is there any way I
can prevent that osteoporosis thing for
happening to a good bull he says well
yeah he says if you'll give a bull calf
10 cents worth of calcium every day
after he's weaned he'll never get
osteoporosis for say no wait a minute
doc you mean if I give that bull 10
cents a day worth of calcium from the
time he's wean I can prevent a
$70,000 disaster oh yeah it's that
simple he says you mean all I have to do
is give up a half a cup of coffee a day
to do that he says yeah that's it he
says I choose that one he say I'll give
up the half a cup of coffee and that's
what we have to think like then there's
receding gums dentist and periodontist
will tell you that if you want to
prevent and cure receding gums you
better floss and brush after every meal
if you believe that works I have some
oceanfront property in Montana to sell
you if you all know your geography you
know that doesn't work now as a
veterinarian I've seen hundreds of
thousands of animals of all kinds mice
rats rabbits dogs cats sheep pigs horses
lions and tigers and bears and they
don't get receding gums
and they don't floss now they do get
funky breath but they don't get receding
gums well if you want to smell something
you just let a camel breathe on you
boy well the reason we don't have
receding gums and livestock is because
we've dealt with the osteoporosis
problem receding gums is not a
deficiency of flossing it's in fact
osteoporosis of the jaw bones and the
facial bones so if you have gingivitis
or receding gums you have advanced Osteo
is those bones around your teeth are
melting away little bit by little bit
every day and if you take your teeth out
at night and put them in a glass next to
your bed and that fizzy stuff you have
major advanced osteoporosis because all
your bone has melted away then there's
arthritis we talked about that a little
bit earlier remember the chicken
cartilage 85% of all arthritis is caused
by osteoporosis of the joint ends of the
bones you're talking about degenerative
arthritis osteoarthritis sciatica
lumbago rheumatism all those sorts of
things things um they're caused by
osteoporosis of the joint ends of the
bones I want you to think about
something for a minute if you don't take
a pain reliever or or an
anti-inflammatory for that arthritis
let's say you get arthritis of the hips
you're going to kind of favor that a
little bit aren't you you're going to
get a cane or a walker or crutches
you're going to favor it and so you
don't put any weight on it I want you to
think about that for just a second
because then I want you to think about
driving your tractor in a field or
you're driving a Mercedes down the
highway either one doesn't matter
whichever you love more let's say you
didn't put the nut on that oil pan real
tight and all the oil drained out and
that light on the dashboard comes on
says I'm getting hot you better give me
some oil and that light irritates you so
you stop you open up the hood you get
your clippers out you know your fence
Clippers and you clip the wire to that
light and you close the hood and you
just keep driving would you do that to
your tractor or your Mercedes no you
wouldn't but we take those pain
relievers for arthritis and we go out
there and square dance and do the Texas
twep and do our F mile walks and our
aerobics that pill Works real good cuz
it killed my pain and you're just
wearing that thing off faster and faster
then your doctor's really going to get
rich because you need joint replacement
surgery then there's hypertension this
is one of my favorites so I'll put a
star over here hypertension is high
blood pressure what's the first
nutritional thing that a doctor will
tell you to give up nutritionally when
you get high blood pressure give up salt
everybody knows that one that's been
ingrained in our head well they must
think we're dumber than cows because
what's the first thing you put out for
your livestock and it's about that big a
salt block no farmer is going to be
economically viable if you don't put a
salt block out for your livestock
they're going to die kind your
Veterinary bills are going to go crazy
but we're supposed to believe that we
don't need salt you can get everything
you need out of your lettuce and your
whole wheat bread and stuff like that
well don't believe that one either if
you believe that I got some more ocean
front property in Montana for you they
took $30 million of your tax money and
two years ago after 20 year study they
came out and said that they took 5,000
people with high blood pressure they
took them off their medication and put
them on a reduced salt diet a restricted
salt diet and they all died no big
surprise but somebody got a PhD degree
and everybody was happy right but when
they looked at this results they said
that oh only 99.7% of the people didn't
get any results from that before they
died 0.3% did get some result dropped
their blood pressure one point before
they died by restricting their salt so
the referees who judged that article
said oh doesn't matter you might as well
let high blood pressure patients eat
salted peanuts and dill pickles and salt
their food to taste because doesn't
matter in fact worrying about the salt
is more stress than taking the salt then
they had a control group with 5,000
people with high blood pressure and they
doubled their RDA of calcium and they
stopped the experiment in 6 weeks
because 85% of them were cured of their
high blood pressure just by doubling
their calcium intake now they didn't
cold turkey stop their high blood
pressure medication but what they did
was they went to the doctor and says you
don't need this medication anymore what
are you doing well I'm on this
experiment where I double my calcium
intake anybody get a recall from your
doctor saying it's okay to Salt your
food to taste and please do double your
calcium intake anybody get that not a
single one that's very interesting then
of course there's insomnia that's where
you roll around all night you wake up in
the morning you're more tired when you
went to bed that's insomnia of course
doctors have two treatments for that
they have hion which is a sleeping pill
and they have barbituates they kill
about 10,000 people a year with
overdoses of those things but that's
okay it's a prescription and they're
watching out for us and remember George
Bush when he went to Japan they gave
gave him some helon so he could sleep on
the way to Japan because of the time
difference and when he woke up one of
the side effects of helon is nausey and
vomiting I don't know how you say it in
Japanese but it was very dramatic on
world TV right not very
presidential and so I'm sure that's why
he lost the election because he puked
over that Japanese
Ambassador and then of course there's
kidney stones and then there's bone
spurs heel spurs and calcium deposits
again Physicians will tell you the first
thing to give up nutritionally is
calcium and dairy because they have this
foolish belief the stupid belief the
ignorant belief that the calcium in
kidney stones bone spurs heel spurs and
calcium deposits come from your diet
when instead it only comes from your
bones when you have a raging
osteoporosis and when you get these
things you need more calcium not less
then there's cramps and twitches is you
wake up in the middle of the night and
your foot is all cramped up around your
neck and you say Lord take me from the
knee down I'm not going to make it till
morning we've all experience that that's
very common then there's PMS
premenstrual syndrome you know the
emotional and physical stuff the medical
treatment of choice for PMS is what we
call a hysterical ectomy it's been
shortened to hysterctomy that's a 100y
old treatment the doctors do about
285,000 unnecessary hysterical ectomies
a year but it makes Mercedes payments so
they do them even the AMA said they're
unnecessary but they don't take their
licenses away and people keep going to
them you imagine a poor woman in her 30s
she says doc you got to do something
every time I go out to hang out the
clothes my neighbors kids run down the
basement screaming witch my own kids
think I'm crazy my husband's leaving me
I'm going to lose my job you got to do
something well the University of
California San Diego came out three
years ago now and said if you just
double the RDA of calcium intake you get
rid of 85% of the emotional and physical
symptoms of PMs and when that came out
there were huge lines around the health
food stores around the blocks and people
had sleeping bags cuz they closed before
they all got their calcium and every
person in line was a
man they were there for their daughters
and their girlfriends and their wives
and things like that okay and lastly is
low back pain 85% of Americans get low
back pain whether you work on a computer
or you unload hay or you drive big
trucks doesn't matter low back is a big
problem low back is just osteoporosis of
the vertebrae whether you have a disc
problem or whatnot because if your disc
doesn't have anything to hold on to your
vertebrae have melted away what's going
to happen to the disc especially if you
have a copper deficiency because they're
made out of elastic fibers they go like
a water balloon with a lot of pressure
on them I just want you to look at this
quickly before we do the last mineral
low back you go to an orthopedic surgeon
or rheumatologist you might get a muscle
relaxant you might get valium and a
muscle relaxing you get a laminectomy
you get your vertebrae fuse you might
get a disc operation they don't tell you
is 75% of the time you'll never be the
same again right PMS you go to your
OBGYN you can um go to an internist you
can go to a family counselor a shrink or
divorce attorney cramps and Twitches you
go to a neurologist you go to a sports
medicine doctor an internist bone spurs
heel spurs calcium deposits you go to a
rheumatologist an orthopedic surgeon or
a podiatrist kidney stones you go to a
urologist or an internist or a surgeon
insomnia go to a shrink or a um Sleep
Clinic or an internist hyper attention
you go to a Cardiologist an internist or
a surgeon arthritis a rheumatologist a
orthopedic surgeon or an internist
receding gums you go to a dentist or
periodontist osteoporosis you go to all
those Health Specialists including a tum
salesman for nothing more than a Calcium
deficiency it cost you 10 cents a day to
deal with now on the average because
Americans have insurance and we have
Medicare and Medicaid we spend on the
average $25,000 to
$250,000 and we undergo 5 to 10 surgical
procedures a year for a Calcium
deficiency and we beg the doctors to do
it we beg the doctors to do it well it's
our choice the last one I'll share with
you is diabetes everybody's touched by
diabetes it's the number three cause of
death in adults in the United States
number three cause of death and it has
terrible complications and side effects
diabetus the side effects include
blindness of many kinds then there's a
kidney failure with dialysis kidney
transplant there's cardiovascular
disease of all kinds and of course that
contributes the number one cause of
death then there is amputations
everybody ought to have one of those
because they're totally paid for in
their health thing they assume that
you're not just going to get one because
you want to get everything on your
health benefits and then you shorten
your life because if you have diabetes
on the average you have a shorter
lifespan than someone who doesn't have
diabetes now we learned in 1957 in the
animal industry that we could prevent
and cure diabetes with two trace
minerals that's pretty profound
statement that we could prevent and cure
diabetes with two trace minerals in 1957
and animals it was published in
Federation proceedings which is the
official Journal of the American Science
the National Institutes of Health the
official monthly Journal was August
1957 well the two trace minerals that
you can get to prevent and cure this are
chromium and vadium vadium alone
according to the University of Vancouver
British Columbia Medical School V ium
alone will replace insulin in adult
onset diabetics which represent 85% of
all diabetics of course they can't quit
their insulin cold turkey they got to
gradually wean off of it takes four to
six months for most people to slowly
wean off of insulin if they're taking in
adequate amounts of chromium and vadium
now to me this is Criminal because if
you write to a Hills packing company
that makes ss. dog food the right over
here in TOA Kansas they manufacture
Science Diet dog food and other Science
Diet product high-tech foods for animals
if you write them and say how many
minerals exactly is in Science Diet for
dog food they'll write you back and say
there's 40 minerals you write the
checkerboard Square in St Louis R and
pan and say just how many minerals are
in your rat pellets for laboratory rats
and they'll say there's 28 minerals I'll
give anybody in this room a crisp new
$100 bill if you can find me a human
infant formula in a grocery store that
has more than 11 so our dogs get FY
minerals remember that's what Mike
Murphy was saying his dog never seems to
get sick cuz he's getting this canned
dog with all these vitamins and minerals
in there so our dogs get 40 minerals our
rats get 28 minerals and our human
infants get 11 is that fair no that's
called
fraud doesn't matter if you're talking
about SMA Similac Isomil Pro soy B fact
that's why they call Similac Similac
because it lacks
everything okay if I've convinced you
that you have to consciously take in all
all the minerals yourself that you can't
depend on your food and certainly you
can't depend on anything that's boxed or
packaged or bottled there's three types
of minerals that you have to be
concerned about one is metallic minerals
and metallic minerals are essentially
groundup rocks metallic minerals are
things like oyster shell eggshell
Dolomite Limestone uh calcium carbonate
Clays of various kinds Mount marinite
clay seabed minerals
Tums they're only 8 to 12% absorbable
When You Reach age 35 to it drops down
to 3 to 5% and I have to tell you a
story here I ran into a guy at a meeting
like this up at Grand Rapids Michigan
and this fellow owns a porta poot
business you know that's that green or
blue colored ouse man if we' only had
one of those back when I was a kid we
had these ones with splinters you know
in the wood he said I see something that
that describes that in my portapotty
business I said what's that he says well
we take those things back to the shop to
clean them out with the pressure hose he
says we put a quarter-inch grid
underneath them because kids throw rocks
and sticks and toys in there and if we
don't put a grid there it blocks up the
sewer system it cost us thousands of
dollars to fix it every time we clean
one of those out we find hundreds of
vitamin tablets I said well how do you
know they're vitamin tablets he says
well it's really easy he says right on
the coating it says teram M One A Day
Centrum he says come here he takes me
out in the back of his shop and there's
this literal mountain of all these
vitamin pills he got out of his porta
potties if you read the labels on those
multiples they say your iron has come in
the form of iron oxide what is iron
oxide rust you might as well just go out
to an old railroad track and take your
butter knife and scrape some of that
rust off and lick it and you're going to
get your iron supplement well that's
what they're giving you I'll show you
how bad it is if you take something like
calcium lactate was which is a common
metallic mineral uh let's say it's a
calcium tab calcium lactate 1,000
milligrams if you take two of those
you're not getting 2,000 milligrams of
calcium in fact I have people all the
time say well I took lots of calcium
doc I hear you on the radio talking
about calcium and arthritis and I took
2,000 milligrams of calcium a day didn't
help my arthritis in fact it got worse
as so what kind of calcium you taken
they said calcium lactate well there's
your problem because only 250 milligrams
of that is metallic calcium so let's say
you absorb 10% of that then the other
750 milligrams is lactose or milk sugar
so 10% of 250 is 25 so if you take two
of those tablets you're not getting
2,000 you're getting 50 milligram so to
get what you need you need to take 90 of
those tablets a day you need to take 30
with each meal and you got 59 more
minerals to
go then there's those people who want to
do things naturally let's see if you can
do anything good with 10 lbs of spinach
and let's be fair let's see if you can
get 1,000 milligrams of magnesium I pick
magnesium because in green leafy
vegetables you have a lot of magnesium
because of the chlorophyll right it's
part of the chlorophyll molecule and any
pound of anything you got 454 G and 10
lb of spinach you got 4540 G of which
most to that 97% is water let's say you
have 1 gram of chlorophyll and that 10
lb of spinach there's 50 mg of magnesium
you got to divide that into the Thousand
you want you get a factor of 20 which
you multiply times the 10 you have to
eat 200 lb of spinach you got 58 more
minerals to
go okay so you got to be a pretty big
person to accomplish all this even as
big as I am you can't get it done so I
prefer to supplement rather than do
those things then of course in the 60s
the agricultural industry came up with
teated minerals because Farmers aren't
dumb enough to pay for a dollar of
something that goes into an animals
mouth and have 99 Cents come out in the
manure I have to really thank Farmers
for being that clever and chelated
minerals are just metallic minerals with
an amino acid or protein or enzyme
wrapped around the metal atom and
increase the absorbability to 40% then
the hell food industry jumped on that
right away because it was a major
Improvement in absorbability of minerals
the most efficient way to absorb
minerals is liquid they're very small
particle size are 7,000 times smaller
than a red blood cell and they're
negatively charged so you actually have
an electrical or magnetic gradient that
concentrates these minerals plants have
a very interesting part to play in
colloidal minerals remember we said that
plants cannot create minerals they're
not in the soil plants can't make them
at any rate metallic minerals are taken
up by plants when they're in the soil
plants convert them in their tissues to
colloidal min minerals and this is how
we store minerals in our body this is
how we use minerals in our body this is
how we transport minerals from their
storage place to their site of use in
the colloidal Farm well our plants our
crops don't have much in the way of
colloidal minerals in them because we
don't have any metallic minerals in our
soil are these minerals important You
Bet Your Life they're
[Applause]
important information and statements
regarding dietary supplements discussed
have not been evaluated by the Food and
Drug Administration and are not intended
to diagnose treat cure or prevent any
disease for more information get back
with the person who gave you this SE